the Biden Administration facing yet
another travel nightmare this time the
FAA forced to ground all U.S flights
this morning for the first time since 9
11. so far it's caused more than 9 000
delays the problem was an issue with a
system that alerts Pilots to potential
hazards nothing special who needs that
Joe Biden says his team is looking into
it
they don't know what the cause is
they don't know what the cause of it is
they're expecting this table within a
couple hours
[Music]
well that boosts my confidence and
despite uh Boy Wonder Pete buttejet
investigating the issue for hours he
still doesn't know what happened
we have to understand how this could
have happened in the first place and
what the original source of the errors
or or the corrupted files would have
been is we need to look at right now and
one of the things I'm asking from FAA is
what's the state of the art in this form
of message traffic I mean there's a
problem with a government system we're
going to own it we're going to find it
and we're going to fix it my top
priority right now is to understand the
root cause understand how it could have
led to this level of disruption judge
he's going for the root cause but I have
to defend him he did tweet on this he
did yeah so I think that for him is
really good like you know what he's so
adorable when he tweets he's adorable
yes okay here's the thing I checked and
the Cabell airport in Afghanistan didn't
have any interruptions today Beijing
airport in China didn't and the Yang the
Pyongyang in North Korea is still
operating okay so they had no problem we
of course did and what I found out is
that Pete butterjudge oversaw the
rebranding of the faulty nodem system to
make it more inclusive and it was
undergoing a two-phase mission so the
question is if the FAA got five billion
dollars in the infrastructure Bill why
is this thing not repaired why are we
seeing more delays more cancellations
than I can remember and the first time
every plane is down and cannot move
since 9 11 21 years ago okay it doesn't
say much for Pete Buddha judge but but
at the at the end of all this you know
he was in charge with the supply chain
crisis you know and I think he was on
paternity leave for a lot of that
although while those ships are off the
coast in California and then uh he was
vacationing in Portugal while they were
trying to do the uh the negotiate with
the rail workers and he goes back and
forth to New York City from Washington
doesn't use a shuttle like every one of
us Dana and uh you know he's just a guy
who's arrogant who doesn't know what
he's doing he's a small town mayor what
did you expect
um you know Danny the judge brings up
the infrastructure Bill uh you know we
they took a trillion dollars and where
did it go I mean are we being too early
to condemn this I think maybe a little
bit but I don't care okay well you know
what I don't think we're early enough
execution yes worse than Watergate nine
eleven files and Jesse's show files in
there
I do think that it's interesting that
you have this one cabinet secretary and
all of these breakdowns seem to happen
all around him and he's always like
we're looking into it and we're going to
blame somebody else not that he's
exactly to blame but the the inclusive
part is that one of the things they did
in December of 2021 is they changed it
from notice to Airmen to notice to air
missions thank God because Airmen is so
offensive yes we solved that big problem
the other reason I think this isn't a
terrible thing for Americans to go
Americans to go through right now is to
ask ourselves a question if Canada has
privatized the air traffic control and
it works very well and it's more
efficient why wouldn't we consider doing
the same thing here why should the
government be in charge of it excellent
question Jessica if we were to impeach
mayor Pete would anybody notice like
like would we lose I mean maybe we don't
even need him maybe it's not his fault
maybe he just doesn't have anything to
do that can be an issue in government
we'll have to check the ratings to see
what would happen if mayor Pete was
impeached and couldn't talk about him
anymore
um
obviously coming off a terrible holiday
season of travel this was not what he
needed to happen and when I saw the post
about it this morning I thought
immediately Cyber attack right how could
it be anything else for to ground PL the
U.S airspace closed right that has to be
cyber check then we hear it's not a
Cyber attack and then I think well
doesn't this make us an obvious Target
for a Cyber attack of this system
because if it can fail on its own then
why wouldn't a Russia or a China or Iran
wake up and say hey guys this is what we
should be going after that was my big
concern then started to see a lot of
Pilots were speaking if they were going
on social media they were showing up and
doing TV hits and they were talking
about how they knew about this yesterday
so why didn't we know about it yesterday
so that people didn't go to the airport
right you don't have as many problems if
everyone doesn't show up for their
flights mayor Pete hid it from us
I'm so glad you I'm not here Jessica
finally I agree with you mayor Pete is
hiding deep dangerous secrets from
America I
not what I said just painting a picture
of what was going through my my little
liberal mind this morning about
um and I think that they need to answer
for it if there's five billion for the
FAA this obviously some of this money
has to go towards fixing the system
which seems quite outdated
um and he when he was on quote paternity
leave he had a child on a ventilator I
would stop saying that he was shrugging
his professional duties if you have a
child on a ventilator
you should be with your child you know
uh Jesse Jessica makes an excellent
point what was mayor Pete doing
yesterday
he could have stopped this uh and I mean
when you hear of that from a Democrat
saying that then you know there's real
trouble here um see I'm just really
proud of the American people that every
single flight in the country was
canceled and there was not a single
homicide yeah it's true I was expecting
a mass casualty event you see when one
person's flight get canceled it's
Bonkers but I'm you know good for you
guys no blunt trauma what do you do on
layovers when this happens Jesse go to
the bar oh you drink you drink and the
fact that people drank and still didn't
assault everybody I think we've come a
long way I'm not saying mayor Pete
you know listen here's what I want if
this happens I want to see ferocity
I want to see someone like this is
unacceptable this is never going to
happen again this cannot happen again
I'm going to get to the bottom of this
and I'm gonna stay here and take every
single question yep but p and this is
why he looks so good he looks like he's
12 because this guy's never stressed
he's like you know what we'll get to fix
it we got this no I don't want that and
I'm not saying it's his fault good I'm
not saying he downloaded some virus from
this computer and it wraps the whole
system although I'm not ruling that out
but he sets the tone for the FAA and the
tone is woke because they're not
spending money on these computers these
computers are 40 years old they're
changing the word Airmen yep because of
transvestite pilot might get offended
like she's not gonna take off or he's
not going to take off because she's cold
today
it's impossible yep and it's transsexual
whoever is do you think transvestite I
did it said transvestite there's an uh
there's a word you don't hear from it's
all right we'll talk about it during the
commercial yes 2023. yeah well wait a
second okay well let's get into this
what is the difference don't do it it's
officially in my ear don't do it we'll
talk about it oh they tell you what to
say okay
hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now